[موسيقى]
يوم حاسم في تاريخ الثورتين المصريه
والتونسيه المجلس العسكري في مصر يعد
بتسليم السلطه الى المدنيين واجراء
انتخابات رئاسيه قبل يونيو
2012 والمجلس التاسيسي التونسي يعقد اولى
جلساته اليوم وسط توافق بين الكتل الفائزه
على تقاسم
السلطات
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ل نناقشه
في عنوانين رئيسيين هل يمثل التطور الاخير
في مصر خريطه طريق حقيقيه لتسليم السلطه
للمدنيين وتحقيق سائر اهداف الثوره
المصريه وما هي العوامل التي جعلت الثوره
التونسيه تنجح عمليا
في تفادي التعقيدات والمخاطر التي تترصد
الثوره
[موسيقى]
المصريه في اخر التطورات الوارده من مصر
اعلن المشير حسين طنطاوي رئيس المجلس
العسكري الاعلى في كلمه للشعب المصري قبل
قليل انه قبل استقاله حكومه عصام شرف
وكلفها بتصريف الاعمال لحين تشكيل حكومه
جديده ونفى طنطاوي اي اطماع للجيش في
الحكم وتعهد بتسليم السلطه فورا من خلال
استفتاء وتعهد باجراء انتخابات في موعدها
كما سيتم انتخاب رئيس للبلاد قبل نهايه
شهر يونيو من العام
المقبل الالتزام باجراء الانتخابات
البرلمانيه في توقيتاتها المحدده
والانتهاء من انتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه قبل
نهايه شهر يونيو
2012 ان القوات المسلحه ممثله في مجلسها
الاعلى لا تطمح في الحكم وتضع مصلحه
المصلحه العليا للبلاد فوق كل اعتبار
وانها على استعداد تام لتسليم المسؤوليه
فورا والعوده الى مهمتها الاصليه في حمايه
الوطن اذا اراد الشعب ذلك من خلال استفتاء
شعبي اذا اتدت الضروره
ذلك لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
تونس الدكتور سالم ابيض استاذ علم
الاجتماع السياسي بالجامعات التونسيه ومن
القاهره الدكتور عمرو هاشم ربيع رئيس وحده
الدراسات المصريه بمركز الدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه
بالاهرام دكتور عمرو نبدا بالاخير بالتطور
الاخير هل من شان ما سمعناه اليوم من رئيس
المجلس العسكري الاعلى ان يهدئ روع الشارع
ان يطمئن المصريين على مستقبل ثورتهم
وربما يعيد المع مصمين الى
بيوتهم الشارع بطبيعته يرفع مطالب ذات سقف
عالي وهو بطبيعه الحال لها طابع مثالي الى
حد كبير وهذا هو لو رفع غير ذلك لكان
الامر غريبا لكن دعني اؤكد ان ما حدث
اليوم او في ختام هذا اليوم من خطاب رئيس
المجلس الاعلى لقوات المسلحه ما من شك
انهم يعد تطور ايجابي ومحمود الى ابعد
الحدود تم انتزاع مكسب كبير ربما لم تكن
لم يكن هناك انتزاع لكافه المكاسب لكن ما
تم حصده ما من شك واضح وكبير كنا نتحدث عن
او كان هناك الحديث عن ما لا يتجاوز سته
اشهر لاعداد لجنه الدستور ما لا يتجاوز
سته اشهر لاعداد الدستور ب نتحدث عن عام
بعدها تج تجرا انتخابات رئاسه كان نتوقع
ان تجرى طبقا لهذا الامر بعد انتخابات
مجلس الشورى بمده سنه يعني كنا نتوقع ان
تجرى هذ تجرى هذه الانتخابات في ربيع 2013
واذ بنا نختصر كل المسافات ويتحدث عن
انتخابات
رئاسيه اقصاها او يحدد لها رئيس الدوله ا
يحدد رئيس دوله مصر فيها في نهايه عام
2000 نهايه يونيو 2006 فهذا مما لا شك
انجاز وانجاز ولكن هذا الانجاز لا يرقى
كما تقول هذا الانجاز لا يرقى كما تقول
الى سقف
مطالب المواطنين في الشارع الان او
المعتصمين على الاقل في الميدان نعم هناك
بعض نعم هناك ما من شك بعض المطالب الاخرى
الخاصه بالمحاكمات العسكريه
للمدنيين هناك امر امور خاصه ما من شك
مرتبطه بطبيعه الحكومه الانقاذ الوطني
هناك خشيه في ان تكون هناك هذه الحكومه هي
تكر رار لحكومه شرف التي كان يحركها
المجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه من خلف
الستار ياتي
بشخصيه لا تختلف كثيرا عن شخصيه الدكتور
شرف او صلاحيات مثل او حكومه منزوعه
الصلاحيات كما كانت هذه الحكومه لكن ما من
شك كما سبق ان ذكرت لك ان ما حدث يشكل نوع
من المكاسب ومكسب بالطبع مهم للغايه لكن
دعني اذكر ك كرك ان ما هو باق في في واقع
الامر بعض المشكلات الرئيسه اضافه لحكومه
الانقاذ متعلقه مستقبل وثيقه السلمي
متعلقه بمستقبل وضع الدستور وكيفيه وضع
هذا الدستور هذه او هذين الامرين اضافه
الى موضوع المحاكمات العسكريه من الامور
المعلقه حتى الان سنناقش كثيرا من الامور
حول اداء المجلس العسكري وان كان هذا
الامر سيغير في الواقع شيئا في مصر ولكن
نتحول الى تونس وضيفنا الدكتور سالم
الابيض وهو استاذ علم الاجتماع السياسي في
الجامعه التونسيه دكتور سالم الابيض دخلنا
في الايام الاخيره في مقارنات بين مسار
الثوره
السلميه مسار الثوره في تونس ومسار الثوره
في مصر
وعوامل هذا المسار ان شئنا نقول السالس في
تونس والوصول الى مجلس التاسيسي وتوافق
بين الكتل الفائزه في الانتخابات حول
تقاسم السلطات والرئاسات الثلاث وبين ما
شاهدته مصر وما يمكن ان نصفه بالتعثر
الكثيره التي يعني مرت عليها مرت بها
الثوره المصريه نسال هنا ما هي العوامل
التي جعلت الثوره التونسيه تنجح عمليا في
تفادي التعقيدات والعقبات التي
رصدناها في الثوره
المصريه شكرا
جزيلا يعني دعني ابدا بتقديم التهنئه
اليوم لاعضاء المجلس سيسي في تونس في
بمناسبه انعقاد اولى الجلسات في هذا اليوم
وهذا اليوم سينحر يعني في تاريخ تونس وفي
التاريخ العربي ككل وهو تتم لمحطات ثلاثه
اولى سبقت هذا الموعد وهي 17 ديسمبر
انطلاقه انتفاضه او ثوره سيدي بوزيد ثم 14
جون في سقوط بن علي ونجاح الثوره و 23
اكتوبر الانتخابات الديمقراطيه الشفافه
التي عرفتها تونس والتي انتهت الى هذا
المجلس التاسيسي الذي يعتبر ثمره مهمه
بالنسبه لهذه الثوره التي قدمت التضحيات
وقدمت الشهداء الذين يترحم عليهم جميعا
بهذه
المناسبه الكريمه بالنسبه لاسباب نجاح
الثوره في في تونس انا اعتقد ان التمشي
الذي عرفته تونس منذ البدايه كان اكثر
وضوحا من التمشي الذي عرفته مصر رغم انني
اق ق كذلك منذ البدايه ان ان هذا التعثر
الذي تعيشه الثوره في مصر هو تعثر لنا
جميعا وهو تعثر لهذا الربيع العربي وتعثر
لهذا الطموح الذي طالما حلمنا به في الوطن
العربي من اجل ان ننجز في يوم من الايام
ثوره ضد الاستبداد وضد الفساد وان نخرج من
دائره الاستثناء العالمي وان تصبح لنا
ديمقراطيات نفتخر بها هذا التعثر هو ما
يرى الكثيرون دكتور سالم هذا التعثر
بالذات ما يرى الكثيرون ان الثوره
التونسيه تجاوزت الكثير من و تجاوزت
الكثير من التعقيدات التي جبهتها واستطاعت
ان تحقق
لهم الشعب التونسي وثوار اهم المطالب التي
ندو بها بينما يقول في مصر تقول القيادات
الشبابيه ان تحركات احتجاجيه الجاريه انما
املاها خطر الالتفاف المحيط بالثوره
المصريه مقارنه
بالمسار المسار التونسي على كل حال قرا
قراءه في المسارين نتابعها في تقرير زميله
رانيا
حلبي اسباب ومقدمات واحده اخرجت التونسيين
والمصريين للثوره على نظامي الحكم
والاطاحه بهما فالبلدان كانا على درجه
قريبه من القمع وانتشار الفقر وسيطره
الازلام والمحاسيب لكن وبعد اشهر من
الثورتين تتاكد صحه ما ذهب اليه البعض من
ان مصر ليست تونس فثوره التونسيه تحقق
نجاحا كبيرا بينما لا تزال تتهدد الثوره
المصريه اخطار جمه الفارق الاساسي بين
الاثنتين هو حصول نوع من التوافق في تونس
منذ البدايه بينما عصفت الخلافات منذ
البدايه بين ارباب الثوره المصريه ومن
التحق بها فيما بعد في التجربه التونسيه
كانت بدايه الخطوات توافق الجميع على
الغاء الدستور القديم فاجر انتخابات لمجلس
تاسيسي وليس برلمان سيكتب الدستور الجديد
ويعيد تشكيل الحياه السياسيه برمتها كما
طبقت اجراءات العزل السياسي على حزب
التجمع الدستوري المنحل الحزب الحاكم ايام
بن علي الشرطه التونسيه نجحت في اعاده
الاستقرار الامني ووقف الجيش على الحياد
ولم يدعي دورا له في حمايه الثوره لاقتناص
مساحه في المرحله اللاحقه لها كما ان
الضغوط الدوليه على تونس ليست بحجم تلك
التي تمارس على مصر بالنسبه للاسلاميين
يرى مراقبون ابتسام خطاب حزب النهضه
بالاعتدال فهؤلاء قالوا انهم ل يتفردوا
بالسلطه ولن يعملوا ضد مدنيه الدوله اقله
حتى الان في التجربه المصريه ياخذ كثيرون
ان الثوره كانت بلا قياده والدستور لم
يلغى من اساسه للتخلص من ادوات النظام
القديم بل اجرى المجلس العسكري استفتاء
على تعديلات على الدستور امر وضع اولى
بذور الخلاف بين القوى السياسيه وفجر ما
عرف بفتنه الدستور فعاشت مصر تجاذبا كبيرا
الدستور اولا ام الانتخابات فكان ان انتصر
منطق الانتخابات او اولا الذي قال به
الاسلاميون وفي مقدمتهم الاخوان المسلمون
من اسباب تعثر الثوره المصريه ايضا وفق
البعض تفتت القوى الثوريه عبر خروج قوى
الاسلام السياسي من منتصف الطريق وادارتها
حوارا منفردا مع سلطه العسكر وتضحيتها كما
تتهم بالمطالب الوطنيه التي وضعتها قوى
الثوره الفعليه بما وجه سهام الاتهامات
لها بانها تريد قطف ثمار الثوره لوحدها
وبعكس تونس رفض الاسلاميون شده مدنيه
الدوله في مصر ايضا تتهم القياده العسكريه
بالتحفظ على كل الاجراءات الثوريه التي
كان من المفترض اتباعها للقطع مع السابق
وبانها تريد حجز مساحه لها في القرار
السياسي في مصر جاء قانون محاربه الافساد
السياسي عوضا عن مطالبات بقانون العزل
قانون من شانه مكافحه تمدد فلول الحزب
الحاكم السابق بينما لا يزال الانفلات
الامني واضحا في مصر تتقدم تونس في ثورتها
وتحقق نتائج مذهله بينما لا تزال الثوره
في مصر
تتعثر ونعود مره اخرى دكتور عمرو هاشم
ربيع رئيس وحده الدراسات المصريه بمركز
الدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه بالهان
دكتور عمرو من خلال كلام المشير قال بانه
بان المجلس لم يدخر جهدا في ان يتم التحول
بشكل سلس وان هناك اكراهات كثيره سواء على
الصعيد السياسي او الاقتصادي او حتى على
الصعيد الاجتماعي وبان المجلس العسكري لم
يكن يقوم باي خطوات الا بالعوده
والاستشاره مع باقي القوى السياسيه في مصر
لكن رغم ذلك سنسمع الكثير والكثير من مما
سماه المشير بتجريح والاتهامات المجلس
بانه كان يتعامل بنوع من الفوقيه مع القوى
السياسيه ومع الثوار وبانه ربما كان يلتف
حول مطالب الثوره والثوار نسال هنا ما دام
المشير لم يصل الى سقف هؤلاء كما قلت قبل
قليل ما هو المطلب الذي كان
ينتظره الشعب المصري ولم ي يستجب له
المشير
طنطاوي دعني عبد الصمد بدايه تكمله لكلامك
او اضافه الى كلامك اذكرك بان هذا الكلام
كان يحمل الذي كان يحمل نقد للمؤسسه
العسكريه او على وجه التحديد المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه كان منبعه ديمقراطي
بالاساس و
لا تستطيع ان تحجر على حريه الراي
والتعبير بدعوه ان هذا فيه هذا الرد فيه
نوع من التجريح او ما الى غير ذلك هذا امر
غير صحيح ناهيك عن ان الاداء بالفعل كان
يحتاج الى
او نعم نع نعم نعم نعم انا انا ادرك ذلك
كان هذا الاداء بالطبع يحتاج الى تقويم لا
اقول هناك كان تقصير متعمد من قبل المؤسسه
العسكريه انت تتحدث عن
مؤسسه عسكريه في الواقع العربي تقريبا
المؤسسه العسكريه الفريده التي كانت تتسم
بالاحتراف بمعنى انها لم تدخل او لم تشترك
في او لم تكن مؤسسه مسيسه ناهيك عن اذا ما
قارنت بينها وما بين ما يحدث على سبيل
المثال في سوريا وفي ليبيا او ما حدث في
ليبيا وما حدث في اليمن انك تتحدث عن جيش
وطني بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمه من هنا كان
النقد
ل عدم وجود الخبره السياسيه في التعامل مع
خلال هذه الفتره الانتقاليه مع الوضع
السياسي في مصر نوع من اداره السياسه يوم
بيوم نوع من التباطؤ في التعاطي مع مطالب
الثوار نوع
من البطء الشديد للغايه واداره الامور
بتمهل غير طبيعي
و الامر الذي ادى بالطبع الى اشعار البعض
بان هناك كما لو كان نوع من التواطؤ خاصه
فيما يتعلق بان كثير من الاجراءات التي
كان يطلبها الثوار صدرت عن احكام قضائيه
كحل الحزب الوطني وكحل المجالس المحليه
وكت اسويت المصريين بالخارج كل هذه الامور
بالطبع لم تصدر من قبل المجلس الاعلى قوات
المسلحه بل صدرت نتيجه احكام قضائيه وكان
يتوقع من المجلس ق المسلحه ان ان تصدر بل
على العكس كافه الامور التي كان يعب بها
بشكل او باخر صدرت نتيجه المليونيات
ونتيجه الضغوط التي كانت تقع من خلفي في
ميدان التحرير ومنها محاكمات رؤوس النظام
السابق اضافه الامور اخرى كثيره خاصه
بقانون العزل السياسي الذي خرج بعد فتره
مبوره هذا التباطؤ هل يبرر اساءه ميه
القوه
والشارع ل بالمجلس العسكري واتهامه ربما
بانه يريد ان يقتل الثوره وينفرد بالسلطه
ويطيل امد وجوده على راس الهرم السياسي في
في البلاد
عبد الصمد انا انا هنا ليس لست في محل
للدفاع عن الثوار لكن ما احب ان انا اقول
لك ان هناك بالفعل بعض الامور التي حدثت
ووقعت كانت في غايه في السلبيه غايه في
السلبيه كما سبق ان ذكرت هناك كثيرا من
الامور حكم بها القضاء ولم تحكم بها
المؤسسه العسكريه او لحق بها المؤسسه
العسكريه في مشروعات قوانين بعد ان صدرت
بها احكام قضائيه هناك بعض الامور
الاخرى المتعلقه بع بيل المثال الشهادات
التي كانت منصفه لانصار النظام البائد
قانون العدد
السياسي اخي عبد الصمد الذي صدر بالامس
كان مبتور الى ابعد الحدود مليء ب هو هو
تعديل
لقانون الغدر واذ بنا نجد ان ث ثله
الاتهامات التي كانت موجوده في قانون
الغدر لم يتبقى منها الا تهمتين فقط كل ما
هو متعلق بالحجر خمس سنوات او الاقص خمس
سنوات كحد كحد كحد ادنى انقلبت الى كلمه
كحد اقصى اصبح هناك الدين طعون من قبل
المعزولين على احكام القضاء بالعزل اصبح
لدينا النيابه النيابه النيابه العامه هي
التي ترفع القضايا هي تفاصيل كثيره دكتور
دكتور هي تفاصيل كثيره نعم هي تفاصيل
كثيره ساهمت في تازم الوضع والوصول الى حد
الانفجار كما شاهدنا في في ميدان التحرير
سنحاول ان نستشرف المستقبل على ضوء كلمه
المشير طنطاوي ونبحث بعد هذا الفاصل الذي
سننتقل الان في ملامح المرحله المقبله
التي تنتظر الثورتين التونسيه والمصريه في
ظل التحديات القائمه في طريقهما نعود
اليكم مشاهدنا الكرام بعد الفاصل ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا من براج
م خبر التي تبحث في اسباب تقدم المسار
الثوري في تونس و تعثره في مصر ونناقش
اوجه المقارنه بينهما نتحول الى تونس
وضيفنا الكتور سالم الابيض استاذ علم
الاجتماع السياسي بالجامعه التونسيه دكتور
سالم الابيض يعني حينما تحدثنا عن مصر
تحدثنا عن عن صراع الان مع المؤسسه
العسكريه التي يراد لها ان تسلم السلطه
الى المدنيين ولكن اذا نظرنا الى تونس لم
يكن الامر كذلك فهل هذا الهدوء اذا شئنا
ان نقول الذي مرت به المرحله انتقال في
تونس يمكن ان نرجع بعض الفضل فيه بعد الله
سبحانه وتعالى الى المؤسسه العسكريه ويمكن
ان يكون تكون للمؤسسه العسكريه التي ظلت
على مسافه واحده تقريبا بين القوه
السياسيه يكون التونسيون مدين مدينون لها
ربما لهذا
التعايش ا اولا في رايي يجب ان نثني ثناء
كبيرا على المؤسسه العسكريه في تونس لانها
بقيت محاي
ولم تتدخل في الصراع السياسي
الموجود وهذا يعود الى ارث طويل يمتد على
50 سنه من ان المؤسسه العسكريه لا تتدخل
في
الحياه المدنيه او لم يعرف على المؤسسه
العسكريه انها تدخلت في الحياه المدنيه
الا استثناء وحيدا وقع سنه 1984 عندما
وقعت انتفاضه الخبز وقع توظيف الجيش
لاخماد تلك الانتفاضه بشيء بقدر ما لكن
لابد من في المقارنه بين الثوره التونسيه
والثوره المصريه ان نعترف ان ما يقع اليوم
في في في مصر وقع في تونس في في بدايه
الثوره يعني دعني اقول في شهر فبراير يعني
والاعتصام الاول والاعتصام الثاني في
القصبه كان يمثل حركه تصحيحيه للثوره لان
الثوره في تونس وقع الانحراف بها في ذلك
الوقت بعد ان قامت بعد 14 جانفي التفت
عليها القوى القديمه بالتحالف مع بعض
القوه المعارضه التقليديه ولكنها اجهدت
تلك العم عمليه بواسطه اعتصام 25 فبراير
المنقضي وكان اعتصام كبير جدا في ساحه
القصبه وكان مثل حركه تصحيحيه باتم معنى
الكلمه وفي هذا الاعتصام وقع نوع من
الاندماج بين مطالب القوه السياسيه
الراديكاليه التي هي قواه يساريه وقوميه
واسلاميه والى حد ما ليبراليه و شباب ثوره
14 جانفي وتبنى هذا الشباب تلك المطالب
وخاصه في ح الدستور وفي حل الحزب التجمع
الدستوري الحاكم السابق وفي الاقرار
بانتخابات مجلس تاسيسي ونحن اذا اردنا ان
نقتدي بالثورات الكبرى في العالم مثلا
عندما نتحدث عن الثوره الفرنسيه الثوره
الفرنسيه كانت احد ثمارها الجمعيه الوطنيه
التاسيسيه الفرنسيه هذا المجلس التاسيسي
هو ثمره كبيره للثوره التونسيه وهو يعبر
عن نضج مسار الثوره وعن استيعاب لقواه
الثوره للمخاطر المحدقه بها لذلك جاءت هذه
الحركات التصحيحيه ي يمكن دكتور عفوا لا
يمكن ان نعتبر المجس التاسيسي في تونس
الان تتويج الثوره لان هناك تحديات كبيره
تنتظر هذا المجلس
ويبرهن حينها حينما يصل القوى السياسيه
تصل الى دراسه الملفات الصعبه من كتابه
الدستور وتوافق حول القوانين الانتخابيه
وغير ذلك هنا سيتم ربما اعتبار ذلك معيار
لنجاح او الفشل
انا اعتبر ربما من منظور التحليل
السوسيولوجي ان ان هذا الحراك السياسي
الذي تعيشه تعيشه تونس هو حراك طبيعي جدا
وان يقع الاختلاف او حتى التناقض او حتى
الصراع بين القوه السياسيه او ان يتحالف
بعضها من اجل تشكيل حكومه فهذا امر طبيعي
جدا لان تشكيل الحكومه يعتبر جزء من مهمه
المجلس التاسيسي بوصفه سلطه تاسيسيه لما
وقع انتخابه انتخابها من اجل وضع دستور
ومن اجل تسير البلاد ولا يمكن تسير البلاد
الا عبر حكومه والحكومه من طبيعه الحال ان
تشكل من قواء الاغلبيه سواء كانت بصفه
حزبيه فرديه او بصفه حزبيه متحالفه وكذلك
ما اراه اليوم في تونس من هذه الحركه
المدنيه كلمه فقط استاذ عبد الصمد ما اراه
من هذه الحركه المدنيه التي نراها امام
مجلس النواب في باردو اراها كذلك حركه
طبيعيه تدل على حراك سياسي ممتاز على اسا
على ارضيه على ارضيه هذا الاختلاف وهذ هذا
التعدد والتنوع الفكري والسياسي ولكن لا
يجب ان تتحول هذه الحركه المدنيه الممتازه
الى نوع من الارباك لدور المجلس التاسيسي
وقيامه بوظيفته الرئيسيه في وضع الدستور
خلاص لم تترك لي المجال لاسال سؤال اخر
لما بقي وقت قليل جدا اخصص لضيفنا في في
مصر دكتور عمر هاشم بعد خطاب مشير طنطاوي
مصر الى
اين
اي ما ذكره المشير طنطاوي فيما يتعلق
بالاستفتاء على المغادره انا اتوقع ان هذا
كان لمجرد الترفع عن او ثبات الترفع عن
السلطه هذه واحده الانتخابات البرلمانيه
سوف تجري في موعدها ولا حرج من ذلك وسوف
يكون اتوقع للتيار الاسلامي الغلبه
العدديه وليس الغلبه المطلقه الامر الثاني
المشكله سوف تجري ايضا اعداد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ويتم الامر في موعده لكن المشكله
عبد الصمد في تقديري سوف تاتي في الدستور
هل هيكون الدستور قبل الانتخ انتخابات
الرئاسيه وهذا مستبعد او شبه مستحيل لضيق
الوقت يبقى انه سوف يكون بعد بعد انتخابات
الرئاسه الامر الذي ينزر باحد عاقبت او
ثلاث عواقب هل سيتدخل رئيس الجمهوريه
المنتخب في وضع الدستور بسلطته المعنويه
على الاقل ام هل تتدخل القوى التي وضعت
لجنه الماءه التي غلبتها من التيار
الاسلامي باعتبار ان هو له الغلبه في
الدستور له الغلبه في البرلمان في وضع هذا
الدستور والمشكله الرئيسه ماذا ستفعل
المؤسسه العسكريه فيما يتعلق بوضعها
ومكانتها في الدستور طالما ان وضع تم وضع
الدستور
في بعد الانتخابات الرئاسه هنا تبدو لي
بعض المشكلات التي ربما قد تحدث وربما قد
يعاد القار مره اخرى لا قدر الله فيما
يتعلق بوضع مبادئ حاكمه للدستور او وضع
مبادئ كما يحلو البعض ان يسميها مقاد
اساسيه او فوق دستوريه ولا قدر الله ان
هذه المشكلات ربما ان شاء الله لا تحدث
نعم ان شاء الله شكرا لك يا دكتور عمرو
هاشم ي رئيس وحده الدراسات المصريه بمركز
الدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه بالاهرام
كما نشكر ضيفنا من تونس الدكتور سالم
الابيض استاذ علم الاجتماع السياسي
بالجامعه التونسيه ونشكركم مشاهدينا
الكرام لمتابعتكم بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج مو الخبر غدا باذن الله قراءه
جديده في مو الخبر جديد اللقاء بحول
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الله
ه